Thì cái chủ đề hôm nay á là mình sẽ trao
đổi với nhau về Google Anti Gravity.
Mình sẽ dùng cái công cụ Anti Gravity
này để đi cào dữ liệu, đi craw dữ liệu
trên các nền tảng website cũng như trên
các nền tảng Facebook, YouTube, TikTok,
Reddit. Không cần mình phải đăng nhập
tài khoản luôn cả nhà thì mình vẫn có
thể được cái data ở trên đó và kể cả cái
phần comment ở phía dưới ha. Ok. Thì cái
này là cái bước giới thiệu ban đầu để
mọi người thấy là cái công cụ này nó
ngoài chức năng vi coding á thì nó có
thể làm được những cái chức năng khác để
mọi người có thể hình dung. thì Minh sẽ
mở lên cái công cụ này trước tiên là mở
cho mọi người có cái tài liệu để mọi
người thấy. Vì ở đây cũng chắc chắn có
một số anh chị em chưa hình dung được
cái công cụ này nó làm cái gì thì mình
sẽ gửi luôn cho mọi người cái cái đường
link này. Xong rồi mọi người nếu tiện
thì mọi người cùng mở với Minh để mọi
người nếu ai kịp thì mọi người cùng cùng
chiất vào cái đường link để tải về thì
Minh nói nó sẽ nhanh hơn.
Đây là một cái công cụ hiểu cơ bản là
khi nó ra mắt á thì mục đích đầu tiên là
phục vụ cho cái việc pha coding à chủ
yếu là vi code thôi ha. Đó là để nhắc
nhở chính á. Nhưng mà sau đó thì trong
cái quá trình mà mình sử dụng cũng như
là số anh chị em mà mình tham khảo ở
trên cộng đồng mạng á mình học hỏi được
từ các anh chị trên cộng đồng nữa chứ
không phải là mình tự khám phá. Và cũng
nói chia sẻ thêm với cả nhà là mình hiện
tại chưa có được một cái app nào từ cái
ứng dụng antiravity này nha cả nhà. Mình
không hề và cũng chưa hề viết được cái
app nào trên này hết. Mình chỉ dùng cái
Google A Studio để viết app thôi. Mình
cũng có chia sẻ trên số cộng đồng nếu
anh chị em biết. Đó cũng nói chia sẻ
thật như vậy. Tuy nhiên á với cái ứng
dụng à này thì mọi người thấy à mình đã
chia sẻ ra có thể đi cào dữ liệu và làm
được cái những cái việc nó cao cấp.
Đây
thì để mọi người tìm hiểu sâu hơn mọi
người có thể đi vào cái đường link này.
Trong này nó sẽ có một cái documentation
này để tham khảo sâu hơn nếu anh chị có
thời gian. Thì hôm nay Minh sẽ chỉ nói
đôi nét về nó thôi. Thì để mọi người nắm
ở trong cái công cụ này nó sẽ có những
cái chức năng gì. À đó là cái model
model AI gì vân vân ha. Thì mình ở đây
mở tài liệu thôi, còn mình sẽ mở lu trực
tiếp ở đây. Thì như ở đây á, ở trong này
ha, mình mở lên đầu tiên cái giao diện
này, mọi người click vào á, nếu chưa có
cái app này, chưa có cái tool này mọi
người vào trong cái mục là download được
không ạ? Mọi người tải về nó như một cái
ứng dụng, một cái software bình thường
và có thể ứng dụng là cài được trên Mac
OSOS, Windows và cả Linux.
Tới đ bước này có có anh chị nào không
kịp thì mình có thể đi ở trong cái phần
tài liệu và sẽ có thấy ha. Thì click vào
cái đường link này thì mọi người sẽ
download về. Nó cũng khá là đơn giản
trong cái việc cài đặt. Sau khi cài đặt
xong á thì nó sẽ ra giao diện như thế
này đó. Và nếu như mình sử dụng cái tài
khoản, cái này là của Google nha cả nhà.
Và nó sẽ sử dụng cái tài khoản của
Gmail. Nếu như cả nhà mà sử dụng mail mà
miễn phí á à thì cũng nhắc nhở nếu như
mà mail miễn phí thì vẫn sử dụng được.
Tuy nhiên tuy nhiên thì mọi người sẽ lưu
ý ha ở chỗ này nó sẽ có cái phần là giới
hạn. Cái số mà mình hiểu cơ bản nó giống
như là cái cota mà nó cấp theo tuần theo
ngày à mình hiểu nó giống như như cơ bản
như vậy đi để mình hình dung là phiên
bản miễn phí thì bị giới hạn và phiên
bản trả phí là bản pro á. Nếu mà Gmail
bản pro mình lock bằng cái Gmail mà Pro
hoặc là Ultra thì cái số lượng radit
này, cái số lượng cota này à nó sẽ cứ là
sau mỗi 5 tiếng, sau mỗi 5 tiếng nó sẽ
hồi lại một lần, phục hồi lại sau khi
hết cái lượng Redit này mình làm việc á
hết cái lượng toen ha cái cota này cứ
sau mỗi 5 tiếng thì tất cả những cái tài
liệu này đã được
được Google họ họ để ở trên này rồi. Mọi
người có thể tham khảo thêm. Ở đây nó để
rất là rõ ha. được refresh every 5 giờ
sau 5 tiếng là sẽ refresh lại một lần.
Đó, đây là cái bản Google One có nghĩa
là tương ứng với cái việc là Google mà
mọi người đang dùng nếu mà phiên bản gọi
là trả phí và bản pro hoặc là Ultra đó.
Còn nếu mà phiên bản mà cá nhân ở đây là
không có nói là ấy là miễn phí thì sẽ bị
giới hạn. Có nghĩa là trung bình nó sẽ
là
đây nè. Quickly mọi người thấy không? Nó
sẽ là quickly. hàng tuần nó bắt đầu nó
mới gia hạn lại sau khi mà hết cái số
lượng này. Vậy nên á thì nếu như anh chị
em nào mà sử dụng mail miễn phí á thì
mình sẽ bằng cách có thể là mình tren
cái tài khoản sang một cái tài khoản
Gmail khác nếu mà Gmail miễn phí được
không cả nhà? Thì ở đây là Minh chia sẻ
thêm với cả nhà về cái công cụ Antiv
Gravity để hình dung ra thêm nó sử dụng
tài khoản gì. Rồi vậy thì ở trong này nó
có cái chia làm ba khung màn hình mà
mình hôm qua mình có chia sẻ với mọi
người á thì nếu như mà lần đầu tiên giao
tiếp thì cũng giống như Minh cũng như
ngày hôm qua ngày hôm kia đó Minh rất là
bở ngỡ với cái giao diện này nhưng mà
mình đã dành khá nhiều lần ngồi khá lâu
với nó để tương tác và sau đó làm việc.
Thì mọi người hình dung ha là bên này nó
như một cái cửa sổ. Bình thường nếu mà
mọi người làm việc giống như filew Excel
gì đó mọi người có th một cái thư mục
thì tốt nhất mọi người cứ hình dung nó
giống như một cái filew đầu tiên cái đã.
Mọi người tạo một cái thư mục có thể là
thư mục làm việc là phòng bank là
marketing. Tại vì lát nữa mình sẽ đề cập
thêm ở trong cái thư mục ổ D mọi người
để luôn là anti Gravity hoặc là thư mục
gì đó mà nó dính chỉ tập trung cho những
cái dữ liệu mà của antiravity. Mọi người
hình dung trước cái đã. Còn sau này nếu
mọi người đi chuyên sâu mọi người có thể
tìm hiểu thêm trên các kênh YouTube hoặc
là các kênh cộng đồng của group Facebook
vân vân mọi người tìm hiểu sâu hơn. Đó
thì ở đây là Minh đang mở ra một cái thư
mục có nghĩa là Zoom tối thứ ba là Minh
chưa động chạm vào và trong đó là Minh
đã có làm thêm hai đến ba cái thư mục
khác là Minh Tết trong đó là marketing.
Ví dụ à Minh mở một cái thư mục
marketing thì mọi người sẽ thấy nó là
cái những cái dữ liệu mà Minh đã làm là
để cả nhà cùng cùng xem qua
ở trong đây nó sẽ có cái gì. Trong cái
lúc mà mình mở cái thư mục marketing á
là cái mà ngày hôm qua bắt đầu mình test
á thì mọi người đợi ha. Trong đây nó sẽ
có lượng dữ liệu gì thì bắt đầu nó lần
phải có thời gian tải cho nên nó sẽ mất
một chút thời gian mọi người thấy ha.
One moment mình. Ok. Thì cái này mọi
người bấm vào trong này nó sẽ bắt đầu mở
ra chỗ này nè. Đây mọi người thấy ha.
Đây là những cái file mà Minh đã tương
tác với lại cái agent bên này để cho ra
được cái dữ liệu bên này được không cả
nhà? Và và đây là cái khung mà giao diện
mà cửa sổ chính mà màn hình hiển thị. Ví
dụ như bên này là cửa sổ giống Explorer
là giống như cái cây mà Window Explorer
giống như trên quản lý máy tính vậy
thôi. Mọi người hình dung chưa ạ? Còn
cái bên khung mà bên giữa là cái khung
hiển thị. Đấy. Và cái khung bên tay phải
á mình hiểu cơ bản đây chính là cái
khung mà mình sẽ làm việc mà mình sẽ
tương tác mình chat với lại cái AI. Tuy
nhiên mọi người phải hình dung thêm cho
mình trong cái tài liệu mình có để luôn.
AI ở đây chính là AI Asian chứ nó không
còn là AI đơn thuần như kiểu là một cái
con AI mà chat GBT hay là AI Gerin. Nếu
như cả nhà đã từng sử dụng cái con Z
GenB ở đây không biết là có anh chị đã
từng sử dụng hay chưa. Trước đây trong
có một số buổi à Minh ở một cái buổi
khác ở trong những cái buổi workshop
cũng có Minh Từng chia sẻ về SB hay là
Manus hoặc là con Flox thì đó là những
cái con AI nó đã được tích hợp theo
chuyển đổi là cái dạng lên Asian và nó
khác nhau với cái AI cái kiểu mà gọi là
truyền thống của mình á là chatbot là
chat GPT đó gọi là chatbot nó chỉ là
giống như tương tác hỏi và trả lời. Còn
mọi người hỏi thì cứ tiếp tục trả lời.
Còn với cái A chỉ với một câu firm mọi
người ra lệnh thực thi thì nó sẽ thực
thi đến cái đến ra kết quả thì thôi. Cái
kiểu kiểu như vậy và nó điao nhiệm vụ
giống như đây là một cái cái nhiệm vụ
đây.
Một cái nhiệm vụ thì mình đi sơ lược
trước. Ví dụ như trong trường hợp này ờ
đây để mọi người hình dung
khi mình gõ một cái câu tr mình chỉ yêu
cầu nó mình chỉ yêu cầu là đây đây nè là
tìm kiếm 10 cái bài đăng mới nhất mình
có để câu ở trong tài liệu không mọi
người bắt đầu có thể cài cái này xong là
mọi người log vào thử rồi mình sẽ đi
từng bước với cả nhà thì ở đây mọi người
thấy nè mình chỉ để cái câu này ban đầu
mình không nói rõ là antiravity của cái
nào thì lúc này nó hiểu đây là
antiravity của một cái ứng dụng tên khác
nó bị cùng tên sau đó mình yêu cầu lại
và mình nói rõ hơn là cái này là
antiravity của germin thì nó đã truy
xuất và nó đưa cái dữ liệu về đúng cái
trọng tâm ở bên này đây mọi người sẽ
hình dung ra cái bài đăng thì nó nằm ở
đây
antiravity
Facebook thì
một câu lệnh thôi nhưng mà nếu với chat
GBT hay là con Rock AI gerin nó không
thể nào mà đi ừ gọi là cào dữ liệu và
cũng như là tương tác để lấy hết sau đó
báo cáo cho mọi người và thống kê ừ đồng
thời cũng như là vẽ một cái hình luôn ừ
tương tác à ra như một cái infographic
bên trong cái documentation của Google
đó mọi người mà mình có nhắc đến cái
trong tài liệu họ có nói rất là rõ ha là
bên trong cái nền tảng này được tích hợp
luôn Nano Banana Pro. Được tích hợp luôn
nano banana Pro. Cho nên khi mình yêu
cầu nó tạo hình ảnh tạo infographic sau
khi đã có này mình nói rất là rõ hãy tạo
infographic nội dung bài viết này và
chèn dưới báo cáo thì mọi người thấy sau
khi đã có cái báo cáo rồi mình yêu cầu
thì lúc này nó sẽ đưa cho mình luôn cái
tổng hợp lại thành một infog chèn dưới
này được không cả nhà? Vậy thì
mình hình dung á với cái antiravity này
á mọi người à anh chị em mà viết code
như thế nào mình chưa rằng mình chưa làm
chưa đụng tới. Tuy nhiên nếu như mọi
người dùng cho cái mục đích là công việc
ví dụ như nghiên cứu chuyên sâu hoặc là
thiết lập những cái ứng dụng mà hồi nãy
Minh có để ở trong cái tài liệu và cũng
như cái bài đăng mà để mà mà trên cái
Facebook mà sáng nay đó thì mọi người
thấy cái tính năng nó hoàn toàn khác. Và
mọi người cũng lưu ý thêm,
mọi người lưu ý thêm trong cái quá trình
mà tương tác, ví dụ như bây giờ Minh sẽ
làm, Minh mở lại một cái thư mục mới và
Minh cùng đi với mọi người để mọi người
thấy cái khả năng mà automation mà tương
tác của nó như thế nào.
Đây. Ok, Minh mở lại cái thư mục mà Zoom
tối thứ ba và Minh sẽ copy đúng với
những gì mà mọi người hình dung nhé.
để cho cả nhà cùng cùng à tương tác.
Cũng có một cái điểm lưu ý nha cả nhà. À
thì lúc này á ví dụ như Minh mở một cái
YouTube và tìm các khóa học về Notion,
mọi người có thể làm một cái thông tin
bất kỳ. Đây đây thì đây là một cái câu
lệnh mọi người thấy nó rất là đơn giản
đúng không ạ? Trong cái quá trình mà
nhập câu lệnh này vô nó tự động nó sẽ đi
mở cái này n mọi người nó trong đây nó
có một cái trình duyệt. Cái trình duyệt
này gọi là của Google nó đã đính kèn vào
ở trên này. Đây mở cho mọi người thấy
nè. Mình mọi người bấm vào bắt đầu nó mở
lên nè. Trình duyệt này không phải là
của bên ngoài mình muốn mở cái trình
duyệt gì thì mình mở mà nó sẽ tự động
trong cái quá trình mà lúc mình yêu cầu
cái này nó sẽ tự động mở cái trình duyệt
local host của của antiravity lên và nó
sẽ yêu cầu mình gì mọi người yêu cầu
mình cài thêm một cái gọi là cái
extension của antiity browser thì lúc
này nó mới đi điều khiển gọi là tự động
được để nó làm cái chức năng gọi là đi
lấy dữ liệu hay là đi đọc thông tin được
không cả nhà? Ok mọi người để ý nhé.
Minh thử nè. Nó tự động nó sẽ mở cái này
ra. Và một cái lưu ý nữa trong cái model
này á ở đây Minh giới thiệu thêm trong
cái model của
của của của cái ô chat cái luồng chat
này mọi người thấy nó sẽ có là Germini 3
Pro high 2 high rồi low rồi flash
cloudet hay là cloudet thinking
thinking. Ở đây mình recommend với mọi
người luôn recommend nhé. Mọi người lưu
ý nè. Nếu như nếu như mọi người mà chỉ
sử dụng hỏi những câu bình thường á thì
mình cứ sử dụng mà germin flash đi cho
nó nhanh. Còn nếu mà yêu cầu cái ứng
dụng mà nó họ đòi hỏi phải cao cấp hơn á
có nghĩa là nó có đi lấy cái thông tin
đọc dữ liệu mà để viết giống như viết
code hay là làm cái gì mà chuyên sâu quá
thì mọi người đẩy lên luôn là 3 Pro 2.
Tuy nhiên á ở trong cái các model này
thì cái model mà cao nhất hiện nay là
Cloud Opus 4.5. thinking thì
ở trong cái quá trình mình chia sẻ mà
nếu mình nói có cái gì điểm nào chưa
đúng mà anh chị em mà đã sử dụng những
anh chị mà đã sử dụng rồi mà thấy nó
không đúng là mọi người cứ góp ý để mình
biết á là Minh cũng muốn được cập nhật
thêm về những cái thông tin này. Tuy
nhiên với bản thân Minh á
>> thì trong cái quá trình mình sử dụng á
thì cái OB 4.5 là cái mà mình ra được
cái kết quả mà mình ưng ý nhất sau khi
mình thử nghiệm với hai ba cái model này
được không cả nhà? Rồi thì ở đây mình sẽ
lấy một cái flash để cho nó nhanh nha
mọi người. Nhìn
thì bắt đầu nó sẽ mở lên cái ô cái cái
tự động nó sẽ open cái YouTube trong cái
trình duyệt của cái cái cái này. Và bắt
đầu đây là cái thao tác gọi là đúng
nghĩa là nó sẽ tự động nó đi thực thi.
Mọi người nhìn ha. Bên này nó vẫn đang
là working và bên này bắt đầu nó sẽ tự
động nó mở một cái ô lên.
À trong cái quá trình mình trao đổi thì
mọi người cứ để cho mình trình bày sau
đó là sau khoảng 8 đến 8:30 sau cái lúc
mình trình bày xong là Minh sẽ ngưng lại
tít xíu để cho cả nhà mình cùng trao đổi
với nhau ha. Đấy thì ở đây nó sẽ mở lên
và nó đi nó tìm kiếm những cái từ gọi là
mình sẽ yêu cầu các khóa học về Notion.
Thì ở đây mọi người có thể yêu cầu nó rõ
hơn. Có nghĩa là khóa học cơ bản hay là
khóa học tiếng Anh hay là cái gì đó vân
vân. Thì cái này mình chị đã tượng trưng
để mọi người hình dung được không cả
nhà?
Ok, cảm ơn cả nhà. Thì ở trong cái này
nó vẫn trong cái quá trình nó đang chạy.
Mình sẽ nói thêm tí xíu trong cái luồng
chat này trong quá trình nó chạy này,
lâu lâu nó sẽ có nhảy lên một cái
confirm nó yêu cầu mọi người nhá. Nó sẽ
yêu cầu mọi người xác thực lại là nếu
như nếu như nó không phải là mọi người
để xong rồi nó automation là mọi người
không cần nhìn đâu, không có đâu nhá.
Lâu lâu nó sẽ yêu cầu mình tại vì nó can
thiệp bằng cái ngôn ngữ Java nó ngôn ngữ
à để nó đi đọc luôn được cái cái cái cái
dữ liệu ở bên trong cái video này được
luôn cả nhà. Nó đi đọc được luôn nếu như
mình cái confirm mình muốn khai thác cái
dữ liệu bên trong cũng như là khai thác
luôn những cái comment ở bên trong. Vậy
thì lúc này nó sẽ yêu cầu à cần can
thiệp sâu hơn thì nó yêu cầu mình là hãy
xác nhận lại confirm ở bên này được
không cả nhà. Vậy nên á lâu lâu mọi
người cũng để ý là thí dụ như treo máy
để đó rồi chờ nó cuối buổi nó tổng hợp
lại á thì mọi người cũng phải để ý là
coi có thông báo gì hay không và mọi
người nhớ bấm cho nó confirm lại để
không thôi á là mọi người sẽ
bỏ đi rồi mọi người quay lại thì lại
thấy nó chưa có xong việc được không cả
nhà? Thì đây là một trong những cái thao
tác mà mọi người thấy không?
Chỉ riêng cái việc này thôi, chỉ một câu
lệnh thôi mà Anti Gravity đã có thể làm
một cách gọi là auto tự động. Thật ra
nếu mà anh chị có sử dụng cái chương
trình gọi là Comet, mình đang sử dụng
ứng dụng Comet. Nếu mà mọi người để ý
cái Comet thì nó cũng làm được cái việc
tương tự. Tuy nhiên cái anh này nó cao
cấp hơn.
Mọi người có thể tìm hiểu thêm ha. Tại
vì ở đây là nó ứng dụng Asian nó khai
thác sâu hơn. Cái thứ nhất à ngoài ra
chat GPT cũng có một cái model mà cũng
có thể là có cái trình diệt web mà để
gọi là automation. Đó thì mọi người hồi
sáng Minh thấy có một bạn cũng có hỏi về
cái này nó khác nhau với chatt như thế
nào
được không ạ? Thì cái này mình nhắc nhở
thêm mình trình bày thêm. Rồi ngoài ra á
mọi người ở đây nếu mà trong cái quá
trình mà cài đặt á mọi người lưu ý nè
trong cái lúc mà cài về á mọi người hồi
nãy có để ý không? Minh có một cái giao
diện ở giữa này. Trong cái quá trình này
nó đang vẫn đang chạy nha mọi người. Cái
ô này vẫn đang chạy. Minh giới thiệu
thêm với cả nhà ở trong cái khung này
được không? Bên tay tay trái thì nó sẽ
có một cái mục extension được không cả
nhà? Mọi người lưu ý mọi người cài giúp
mình thêm hai cái công cụ này. Một cái
là Office Viewer và một cái là
antiravity cota để làm gì ạ?
À hồi nãy lúc mà mọi người có để mà cái
giao diện mà mọi người thấy cái phần
trình bày của mình ở trong này nè. Cái
phần hồi nãy mình làm được cái báo cáo
mà nó đi nó report của cái Facebook buộc
phải có cái offic viewer này nó mới hiển
thị cái file gọi là cái nội dung MD định
dạng gọi là format down đó thì nó mới
hiển thị lên được. Cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ
hai cái antiravity cota này mục đích để
làm cái gì? À mình để mục đích là để nếu
mà mọi người không cài cái này vào á nó
sẽ không hiển thị lên cái phần này thì
mọi người sẽ không có đo lường được,
mình không kiểm soát được là việc là
mình đang sử dụng hàng ngày á là cái số
lượng cota hiện nay của mình nè, cái
model này còn bao nhiêu phần trăm. Thật
ra cái này mình cài để mình quản lý mình
kiểm soát thêm thôi chứ cũng tùy mọi
người có nhu cầu thì mọi người cài không
có nhu cầu mình có thể bỏ qua được không
cả nhà? Vậy thì bây giờ mình sẽ đi qua
luôn cái này đi để mọi người hình dung
ha.
nó sẽ có số lượng nó ít hơn thì mọi
người sẽ hình dung coi cái câu chuyện gì
sẽ xảy ra và Minh sẽ sử dụng lên cái
model này để mọi người hình dung nó khác
biệt như thế nào.
Hãy truy cập à 10 bài đăng mới nhất.
Đó thì cái công việc đó cũng chỉ là
những cái làm như cái thao tác như hồi
nãy mình có trình bày với cả nhà đó. Nó
chỉ đơn giản là mình hình dung ra là
mình đang muốn cái gì được không cả nhà?
Mình đang muốn là khai thác dữ liệu từ
cái nguồn dữ liệu nào thì mọi người đưa
vào bên trong cái confirm như vậy.
Rồi cứ như vậy thì mọi người tương tác
trong quá trình đó là mọi người chờ được
không cả nhà? Mọi người hình dung đây.
Bắt đầu nó sẽ đi làm việc nè. Bắt đầu nó
open cái ở đây nhá. Ở đây mọi người lưu
ý nếu như trước đó mình đăng nhập mình
login vào luôn cái tài khoản mà mà
Facebook á mình log vào luôn thì nó có
thể nó khai thác được sâu hơn. Ở đây nó
có cảnh báo cho mình nha. Nó có cảnh báo
đàng hoàng. Thật ra là nó vẫn đi lấy
được nó vẫn cào được dữ liệu. Tuy nhiên
mức độ mà nó cào được bao nhiêu phần
trăm cái này là mình cũng để nói rõ đúng
cả nhà nè. Nó cào được bao nhiêu phần
trăm và có hết hay không. Thì mọi người
cần phải check lại, double check lại sau
khi nó trả thông tin về để tránh trường
hợp là nó bị sót ở trong cái phần đây nè
mọi người thấy không? Nó tự động nó đi.
Mặc dù mình không cần lock tài khoản vào
nó vẫn lấy được thông tin cho mình nhưng
mà còn cái lượng mà content ở bên trong
á có lấy được hết hay không thì mọi
người cần phải double check lại. Tuy
nhiên theo cái recommend của nó là nó
yêu cầu mình lock cái tài khoản Facebook
để có thể ờ vào bên trong mà không hạn
chế.
Kiểu như vậy. Và mọi người thấy không ạ?
Ở đây nó sẽ khai thác bằng cách là nó đi
vào từng cái bài viết một, từng cái
thông tin để bắt đầu nó đi nó chiất và
nó cào.
Ok không cả nhà?
Thì mình nghĩ là mọi người đang quan tâm
đến cái vấn đề này. Tại vì hiện nay á
cái việc mà đi raw đi cào dữ liệu này á
nó cũng có những cái extension tuy nhiên
nó vẫn có những cái hạn chế của nó. Còn
với cái công cụ này á, sau khi mà nó ro
được cái dữ liệu mình có thể nhé, mình
có thể mình có thể mình cho nó dựa trên
cái
>> cái báo cáo này mình lập thành một cái
flame content luôn cả nhà. Flame content
cho cái inside mà mình đã khai thác
được. Mình hình dung được không cả nhà?
Và Minh đã triển khai thử. Và cái flame
content đó mình cho khai luôn trong 1
tháng cho cái kế hoạch của mình.
À thì như vậy cũng với những cái câu
lệnh cơ bản thôi. Cái câu lệnh đó thì
mọi người ờ có thể hình dung rõ là sau
khi xong cái này nè nó sẽ có gợi ý hoặc
là mọi người có thể tự đánh ra là tôi
muốn lập một cái content flank content
gì đó cho cái insiz này thì lập tức nó
sẽ dựa trên cái báo cáo này để nó lập ra
một cái kế hoạch rất là chỉnh chu. Đấy
là cái mà mọi người hình dung ra là bây
giờ với AI agent nó sẽ khác biệt với AI
mà chatbot. lúc trước như thế nào được
không cả nhà? Mọi người sẽ không thể nào
cùng một câu lệnh mà đưa qua bên kia mà
yêu cầu nó làm được hết tất cả những cái
việc này. Thì đây là cái antiravity nó
có thể làm được việc này. Ngoài ra á thì
giống như hồi sáng Minh có có trình bày
với cả nhà ở đây á nó có thể tạo được
luôn cái phần hình ảnh sau khi đã có cái
report rồi. Một cái báo cáo mọi người
nếu mà thấy chưa ổn mình muốn luôn báo
cáo cho sếp ví dụ vậy nhé. mình có thể
lập ra những cái phòng ban ví dụ như à
phòng marketing, phòng gì
nhân sự, phòng kinh doanh vân vân. Rồi
sau đó là mình báo cáo lên sếp thì mình
có thể tạo luôn trực tiếp hình ảnh giống
như sáng mà mọi người đã follow Minh
trên cái nền tảng Facebook để có thấy
Minh đã có chụp lại cái màn hình đó là
cái cái hình ảnh mà mình đưa lên.
À tôi
cái này trong quá trình nó chạy thì mình
cứ để cho nó chạy tí xíu.
Mọi người lưu ý ha. Ở trong đây mình có
một cái phần nữa mình lấy của tham khảo
từ cái của bạn Nguyễn Duy Tùng. Nếu mà
anh chị em nào mà trên Facebook có thể
tìm hiểu thêm cái Antia Gravity này á
thì có thể se thêm cái Facebook của bạn
Nguyễn Duy Tùng. Thì trong đó có chia sẻ
một cái câu firm mà mình thấy khá là tâm
đắc, khá là ưng ý và mình cũng có để
trong này đó là kiểm tra cái độ an toàn
của cái extension trước khi cài đặt được
không cả nhà?
Hiện nay mọi người cứ lấy cái extension
mọi người cài vào trong những cái gọi là
cái này nè cái extension cái add on rồi
đó cái cài vào bên trong cái nền tảng
này nhưng mọi người có hình dung được là
mọi người đang bị thu thập dữ liệu ở mức
độ bao nhiêu phần trăm hay không và thu
thập đó cái việc đó bị có đáng lo hay
không?
Mọi người hình dung không ạ? Ở đây mọi
người copy đúng cái phần này nè. Copy
cái phần này
mọi người cũng đưa vào cái ô chat này
được không cả nhà? Sau khi đưa vào cái ô
chat mọi người quay lại mở cái cái cái
đường link này nè. Cái extension mà mọi
người đang muốn cài là cái extension gì?
Mọi người gõ vào cái đường link copy cái
đường link đó.
Cái này là mình đang mượn lại luôn 100%
cái câu và cái nội dung của bạn Nguyễn
Duy Tùng ha.
Đấy mình sẽ lấy cái phần extension này
được không cả nhà?
Nghĩa là mọi người lưu ý ha à những anh
chị em mình hay cài đặt những extension
này á thì không phải lúc nào nó có cũng
có rủi ro. Tuy nhiên á mọi người cần
check trước, double check trước khi với
công cụ này bây giờ nó là một agent nó
rất là mạnh và nó có thể đi kiểm soát
được à nó cào và nó đọc được là cái tỷ
lệ bên trong đến mức độ đó luôn mọi
người. Và mình đã check lại cái câu này
rồi ha. Mọi người có thể thử thì với cái
câu lệnh đó mọi người đây mọi người copy
đúng cái dòng này sau khi mà vào cái
extension này mọi người copy
hãy qua bên cái a câu confirm này
mọi người điền vào đây nè
được không kể nha. Đấy mọi người điền
vào đấy thì với cái phần này
đưa thẳng qua bên cái antiravity này để
cho cái con AI Asian nó hoạt động nó sẽ
tự động nó đi nó đánh giá rồi nó thiên
kinh rồi nó cào để nó đánh giá là cái
extension này có lấy dữ liệu mình hay
không và tỷ lệ lấy đó an toàn hay không.
Đấy chính là cái phần mà mọi người mình
sẽ lưu ý.
À rồi bây giờ trong cái quá trình mà nó
đang đ đang chạy cái này ha là Minh sẽ
đi trả lời hoặc là Minh sẽ cùng giao lưu
với mọi người để có một bạn Đặng Quốc
Hùng có hỏi là à em tập trung lắm mà từ
nãy giờ em chưa hình dung được cái ứng
dụng con antiravity này làm việc gì
luôn.
Nếu như nếu như nhé với trường hợp mà
các bạn làm về bên marketing, các bạn
cần gọi là hoặc là đi nghiên cứu thị
trường hoặc là đào sâu vào một cái mình
á mình thì làm bên YouTube mình bên
YouTube cũng không phải là chuyên sâu gì
đâu cả nhà. Tuy nhiên á là mình muốn
biết cái content, mình muốn đào sâu vào
những cái mãng A, mãng B, mãng C. Như
vậy thì nếu như nhé, nếu như bạn Hùng
hình dung nếu như mình ngồi ở đây mà
mình ngồi mà mình ngồi mình đi search
bằng tay hay là đi hỏi chat GPT hay hỏi
Gemini thì bạn nghĩ là mình sẽ mất bao
nhiêu thời gian để bạn vào tất cả những
cái nền tảng mà Facebook này ha tất cả
những website này để lấy thông tin. Cái
thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai là để mình biết
được ở ngoài kia những cái bài đăng có
liên quan về cái chủ đề này, mọi người
đang nói về nó như thế nào, mọi người
đang bàn tán về nó như thế nào? Hay là
mọi người đang discuss với nó về cái chủ
đề này như thế nào.
Bạn bạn Hùng có hình dung kiện không ạ?
Ok chưa cả nhà? Thì tới đây nè bắt đầu
lưu ý nè.
Ở đây bắt đầu nó đã cào ra xong rồi nè.
Nó đã cào ra xong. Tuy nhiên nè mình mở
ra cho mọi người xem nhé. nó đã cào ra
xong nhưng mà nó chỉ được trình bày ở
cái dạng bên này là của cái Aion nó
trình bày mình sẽ kêu nó là hãy
lưu
lại là à nội dung này
nội dung
báo
chỉnh
rồi
chấm md
à cái định dạng mà md chính là định dạng
mà gọi là mdown thì cái này nếu mà cả
nhà chưa biết thì có thể search thêm
giùm mình ở trên Google hoặc là hỏi các
công cụ A2 nha cả nhà.
Đấy thì ở đây á là sau khi mà cái bài
phân tích nè mọi người nè nhìn nè à
trong cái quá trình nó làm á thì mọi
người cứ để cho nó mở ha cho nó đây đây
cái cái là cái bài nó phân tích nó đánh
giá nè.
Tuyệt vời. Tôi đã hoàn thành việc tìm
kiếm và thu nhập dữ liệu về 10 bài đăng
mới nhất có liên quan đến antiravity. À
đây là bản báo cáo phân tích các bài là
tập trung về fanpage nè, hướng dẫn vi
coding, chia sẻ kinh nghiệm thực tế vân
vân. Thì bản thống kê chi tiết trong cái
bản thống kê này nó sẽ thống kê luôn
giúp mình á là ngày giờ đăng, loại bài
đăng, lượt like cái bài này được bao
nhiêu lượt like. Ví dụ như hồ thương
tính.
Cái này nó đang nằm ở bên cái khung mà
của chat cho nên nó vẫn sẽ chưa hiển thị
được. Giống như ban đầu mà mọi người
nhìn thấy là nó trình bày dưới dạng MCO
mà mình nói là mọi người cài cái ô offic
viewer á nó sẽ hiển thị đó thì mọi người
sẽ thấy nó rõ hơn. Còn bây giờ trước mắt
thì nó đang đang
à kích thước lại mọi người đợi ha nó
đang generate để nó lưu lại thêm một cái
file MC down nè. Rồi trong quá trình đó
thì mình nói thêm để cho mọi người hình
dung. Thì với cái nội dung này đây chúng
ta sẽ phân tích ra được cho cái hiệu
suất của bài đăng là hồ thương tính được
không cả nhà? Với 92.000 hàng tổng lượt
tương tác là bao gồm à có 646 lượt like
và bao nhiêu đó được không cả nhà? Xu
hướng nội dung nè, video review có tính
gì đó là tính tương tác cao nhất, bài
viết để hướng dẫn, thời điểm đăng đó tập
trung nhiều, nội dung được quan tâm, kết
luận khuyến nghị vân vân cộng đồng gì đó
vân vân. Thì ở đây mọi người hình dung
là nếu như mình làm việc bằng tay ở đây
nhé, mình làm việc bằng tay mà mình ngồi
mình đi mình cào hết cái đống mà gọi là
để coi coi lượt tương tác nè, lượt like
nè, rồi lượt comment. Mọi người có hình
dung ra được ở đây là mình làm có nổi
hay không? Đó là cái ý thứ nhất. Cái ý
thứ hai
à mọi người có thể lấy những extension ở
trên cộng đồng mà mọi người tham gia vào
những cái cộng đồng a á như mình thấy có
anh anh Vương Nguyên Bình thì phải á có
chia sẻ về những cái dạng mà làm cái
extension để mà lấy cái cái cái cái cào
cái là dạng content trên các nền tảng
như là TikTok, YouTube hay Facebook hoặc
là mình có thể lên đó mình lấy về để
mình cào ra. Tuy nhiên mọi người thấy
không? Khi mà mình sử dụng với Aent nó
sẽ như thế nào đây cả nhà?
Ừ. Nếu như lúc nãy mình không cài cái
extension Office Viewer nó sẽ không ra
cái này được không cả nhà?
Đây và cái này mọi người hình dung nhé.
Nó giống như mình hiểu là cơ bản là cái
kiểu kiểu như của
Few được không cả nhà? Nó có thể chỉnh
sửa rồi tô đen, tô đậm, bôi đen, bôi đỏ
để mà nó có thể chỉnh sửa lại được không
cả nhà? Đây là cái offic viewer. Khi cái
nội dung này nó trào về và nó trình bày
bên này, bây giờ là mọi người sẽ thấy
rất là rõ
đó.
Được không cả nhà ơi? Thì khi này á ở
đây mọi người sẽ đánh giá được rất là
nhanh cái bài đăng của anh này, bài đăng
của anh kia, lượt tương tác bao nhiêu,
tỷ lệ tương tác như thế nào và cái nội
dung nào đang mang viral nhất được không
cả nhà? Rồi thì ở cái tình huống này á
mình sẽ yêu cầu nè, mình sẽ yêu cầu mình
mình thấy bắt đầu nó có nè, nó để là bạn
có thể mở file này là cái gì cái gì đó
inside thực tế. Bây giờ ví dụ nhá.
Ví dụ à mình sẽ yêu cầu nó là lập lập
giúp mình luôn đi. À lập
giúp tôi
content plan
cho inside.
Mọi người khi trong quá trình làm mọi
người có thể là cụ thể hơn hôm nay Minh
chị chia sẻ mang tính chất là trao đổi
cho nên mình sẽ đi nhanh và mình không
cũng không có nhiều thời gian
thử coi nó làm cái gì. Đấy mình chỉ
tương tác như vậy thì lúc này nó sẽ bắt
đầu nó lại đi tiếp tục
nè. nó nó hỏi mình để mình nó muốn biết
rõ hơn về cái nội dung rồi sau đó nó bắt
đầu nó đi làm
nó sẽ lật cho mình một cái content flame
rồi mọi người thấy chỗ nào mà chưa được
hay là như thế nào mọi người sẽ có cái
tổng quan và mọi người chỉnh sửa tiếp ở
trong này còn chi tiết là mọi người muốn
làm mọi người có thể cái confirm nó rõ
ràng hơn thì mọi người sẽ ra được cái
kết quả mong muốn đúng với nhu cầu của
mình hơn được không cả Nà
>> anh Minh ơi, em hỏi trước.
>> Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ờ cái con này thì em đang thấy là nó phù
hợp với lại cái nhu cầu mà mình muốn đi
như kiểu là phân tích thị trường gọi là
ờ giống như là khi mình làm YouTube hoặc
mình xây kênh hoặc mình có thể đi search
những cái
chen đúng không anh?
>> Ừ
>> mình xem là cái cái cái ngách mà mình
đang muốn làm á thì bây giờ mọi người
đang làm như thế nào? có bài nào là hiệu
quả đúng không? Mình có thể search ra
cái ờ những cái kênh của đối thủ mà nó
đang hiệu quả. Sau đó là mình sẽ nghiên
cứu được vào từng cái link của những cái
bài viết đấy hoặc là những cái video đấy
đúng không?
>> Đúng đúng đúng. Có nghĩa là ở đây mà anh
anh sẽ quay lại cái trường hợp này. Hồi
nãy là cái con antiraity nó sẽ tự động
nó mở lên n mọi người nhìn nhé. nó sẽ tự
động mở lên những cái size, những cái
bài đăng rồi đây nó sẽ tự động vào đây.
Nó tự động vào cái từng từng
>> Ừ. Thế nó nghiên cứu đến cái phần nào là
nó tự nó mở cái size đấy cho mình luôn
đúng không?
>> Đúng đúng.
Cái này về cái ứng dụng mà nếu mà mọi
người dùng nhiều bên cái
cái cái cái coap mà trước đây nếu mà mọi
người đã từng dùng thì mọi người sẽ hình
dung ra được cái cách làm hoặc là cái
ứng dụng của một số cái nền tảng mà của
chat GBT đấy. CH GPT nó sẽ cũng có một
cái ứng dụng gọi là chuyên làm cái trình
duyệt mà để đi automation đấy hoặc là
con manus ngày xưa manus khi mà manus AI
ra mắt cũng có cái vụ là automation cái
kiểu này. Tuy nhiên á là với cái con
antiravity này á nó sẽ có điểm mạnh hơn.
Sau khi nó tự động nó lấy cái này về và
nó tổng hợp lại thành một cái bài cho
mình thì mình có thể lại tiếp tục tiếp
tục ở đây nhá. Mình làm những cái việc
là mình yêu cầu nó làm ờ ra được những
cái inside hay là những cái báo cáo hay
là những cái chi tiết. còn nhiều gấp hơn
nhiều lần so những cái việc khác. Ví dụ
tiếp một cái trường hợp khác ở trong
này, mình đứng t trực tiếp ở trong cái
luồng này. Mình muốn tương tác với một
cái file khác, với một cái folder khác
mà mình đang có. Ví dụ mình ở đây là
mình đang nói chuyện với mọi người trong
cái buổi tối Zoom hôm nay nhưng mà mình
muốn link với cái dữ liệu của cái thư
mục riêng của mình. Hay là ví dụ trực
tiếp đi, cái phòng ban kinh doanh hay là
phòng ban marketing họ muốn link, họ
muốn nói chuyện với nhau để lấy dữ liệu
trao đổi với nhau thì yêu cầu nó phải
như thế nào đúng không ạ? Thì lúc này
mình chỉ có việc tương tác là hãy gọp
link, hãy mở cái này đây nè. Mình có thể
yêu cầu nè. Đó, chỉ đến cái file trực
tiếp mà cái file mình đang có hoặc là
chỉ đến cái thư mục mà mình đang có ở
trong cái trước đó nữa đấy. A+ mình sẽ
đi đến được cái thư mục và cái tệp đó.
Và mình yêu cầu à giữa cái file đang có
và cái số liệu của nền tảng bên kia đang
có. Mọi người hình dung không ạ? Giống
như mình làm làm việc trong công ty đi.
Ví dụ như bây giờ là nhân sự của tôi là
bao nhiêu đây nè. Và bên bộ phận tài
chính á báo cáo là hiện nay cái tài
chính của tôi nè cái cái cái bộ phận tài
chính kế toán của tôi hiện nay còn ngân
sách bao nhiêu đây nè. Vậy thì nếu như
với lượng dân sự này, với lượng tài
chính này thì tôi còn khả năng là tết
này thưởng ra chi thưởng được bao nhiêu?
Mọi người hình dung kịp cái bài toán đ
không ạ? Vậy thì lúc này á ở đây AI
agent mình cái chỗ này mình có thể tương
đác bằng cách đó luôn. Mình chỉ cần A+
và mình yêu cầu nó. Thí dụ như bây giờ
tôi muốn là bạn đối chiếu giúp tôi là
giữa cái file này và cái ứng dụng kia.
Đây mình sẽ mở ra. Mọi người thấy không?
Đây là những cái mà file trước đó mình
đang có nè.
Đấy mình đã làm trước đó rồi sau đó mình
yêu cầu đó là mình tương tác. Nhưng mà
tại vì hai cái luồng này nó đang khác
nhau. Mình không có có trình bày cho mọi
người để nó nó ấy. Nhưng mà mọi người
hình dung khi mà mọi người thử á mọi
người có thể làm thì lúc này mọi người
kêu nó so sánh báo cáo hoặc là gọp lại
mệt lại đó hoặc là thêm hoặc là bớt nó
làm được hết rồi sau đó cho ra một cái
báo cáo mới để gửi xếp được không ạ?
Cách làm nó là như vậy.
Đây thì ở đây mọi người hình dung nè.
bắt đầu nó ra được
content flame nó sẽ tự động bắt đầu lúc
này nó đã lưu
đây
được không ạ?
Và cái content này mọi người có thể
chỉnh sửa lại. Ở đây mình chỉ mới nói
với nó một ý duy nhất thôi. Rồi bây giờ
nó cho ra mình đây một cái kế hoạch chi
tiết.
Content là bốn chủ cộng chính là
education rồi mục tích truyền cảm hứng
gì đó. dựa trên cái bài đăng đó là bắt
đầu mình à chi tiết ở đây là nó có những
cái nội dung liên quan về cái vấn đề gì.
À đó thì mọi người sẽ đi xem ha. Thì nó
sẽ đi vào từng phần từng phần và thậm
chí á là mọi người thấy là nó làm cho
một cái bản kế hoạch là dài dài đăng
đẳng. Ờ trong đây nó kêu gọi hành động
như thế nào mọi người hình dung không ạ?
Cái trụ cột chính của cái ngày thứ tư đó
là cái gì và định dạng của nó là cái
ngày này là cái gì? Thì cái buổi hôm nay
á do mình sẽ đi nhanh cho nên mọi người
sẽ vẫn chưa hình dung kiệt. Tuy nhiên là
mình sẽ để cho mọi người có cái nhìn
tổng quan về cái con AI Aan của Antia
Gravity này. Nó không chỉ đơn giản chỉ
là để mọi người gọi là là là tương tác
giống như
kiểu mà mọi người đang nghe là
là
viết code vi coding vân vân. thì ở đây
nó có thể làm được những cái việc này.
Ok. Thì à
cái cái cái đến đây thì chắc có lẽ Minh
sẽ tạm ngưng để mọi người mình cùng giao
lưu và mọi người mình đ cùng đặt câu
hỏi. Thì không biết là mọi người có có
có gì thắc mắc hay không. Tại vì trong
cái phần tài liệu nhá thì Minh cũng có
để thêm để mọi người nếu ai chưa chưa
chưa chưa nắm thì mọi người cũng có thể
lưu ý thêm những cái phần này mọi người
lên trên cái kênh chính của cái cái kênh
YouTube chính á của của này để tham khảo
hoặc là search ở trên đó thêm nếu mọi
người quan tâm được chưa không ạ. Còn
cái documentation này á chính là cái
đường dẫn chính mà cái này á nội dung
này á nếu mà mọi người rành á thì như
nãy mình có nói ở trong này có rất là
nhiều cái tài liệu mà mình thấy á bản
thân mình cũng phải nghiên cứu ở trong
này thôi. Phải nghiên cứu thêm cả nhà
chứ không có cái cái
tài liệu hiện nay trên trên trên về cái
này bằng tiếng Việt nhiều đâu. Đó. Đây
mọi người có thể vào xem chi tiết hơn để
nắm rõ ừ Aent thì trong này có bao nhiêu
model và mỗi một model nó sẽ làm gì chi
tiết. Đây mọi người thấy nè nó có nói
nè.
Đó. Rồi vậy thì Asian mod là cái gì? Thì
trong đây nó có nói là convention nó
liệt kê và các quy tắc rồi các nhiệm vụ
thì ở trong này nó có sẽ liệt kê chi
tiết.
Rồi thì chắc có lẽ là tới đây thì mình
tạm thời ngưng và mình cùng giao lưu với
nhau tại vì theo kế hoạch là mình sẽ
khoảng 9:00. Hôm nay mình sẽ ngưng
à nếu mà cả nhà mình tiện thì mọi người
cứ bật mic để mình trao đổi luôn cả nhà.
Còn nếu mà ai mà chưa theo kịp thì có lẽ
mình sẽ
hẹn gặp với nhau trong một cái buổi
buổi sau để mọi người mình cùng trao
đổi. Còn hôm nay thì mọi người cứ bật
mic và cùng cho giao lưu.
>> Ủa anh anh Minh ơi nãy là vào là anh new
anh tạo new một dự án rồi anh kêu nó làm
các thao tác như là lên login Facebook
sau đó rồi tìm content như vậy đúng
không anh Minh? Hồi nãy là là do em đang
ở lúc bằng điện thoại nên em chưa theo
á.
>> À đúng rồi đúng rồi. Tại vì ở trên điện
thoại nhiều khi cái
>> ờ em không nhìn được cái màn hình nên
thành ra là bây giờ em mới on lên máy em
mới thấy thì cái này cũng
>> à đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng. Nó hơi
bất tiện. Nó hơi bất tiện. Đúng rồi đó
Huy ơi. Có nghĩa là mình sẽ mình sẽ cài
cái đặt ứng dụng này trên máy tính xong
rồi mình Anh có gửi cái file tài liệu
rồi ha. Thì trong đó đó thì trong đó là
mình chỉ có new thôi. Mình mở cái new
cái giống như là mở mới mở mới
>> chứ cũng chẳng có làm gì đâu. Rồi sau đó
là mình đưa cái phần câu lệnh mà mình
muốn mình muốn thí dụ như là đi tìm dữ
liệu về các khóa học liên quan về cái
notion hay là các khóa học về AI hay là
các khóa học gì đó vân vân. Đó là câu
lệnh rất là bình thường. Kế đến thì nãy
em có đưa thêm một cái việc là đi cào dữ
liệu Facebook thì nó cũng tự động nó làm
thì nó nó sẽ tự động nó mở các tab ra
như thế này.
>> À anh chọn model này là là là Zemini Pro
luôn đúng không?
>> Ờ thì hồi nãy em có trình bày đó trong
cái phần mà nếu mà chọn model á nếu mà
mình chọn mà pro á đối với những cái
thao tác bình thường mình cứ chọn bản f
cũng được. Ger cho nó nhanh. Còn nếu mà
mình chọn à mình chọn mà mình muốn nó đi
sâu hơn thì mình sẽ chọn lên pro.
À còn nếu mà cái gì mà có liên quan đến
ngôn ngôn ngữ gọi là lập trình mà chuyên
và viết code và viết ứng dụng á thường
luôn á là mọi người sẽ chọn đó là bản
Germini Pro 2 hoặc là cái bản cloud á
cloud gọi là cloud OB 4.5 á Thinking
thì thì ở đây nè để mình mở lại cái cái
cái này để cho mọi người thấy nhé.
Marketing.
Ok.
À đây nó hỏi là mình có lưu
mình có lưu lại cái này mình mở lại cái
thư mục của mình
để mọi người thấy được cái bài đăng của
Minh mà lúc sáng là mọi người thấy mọi
người hình dung ha.
Đây
đây là cái tương tự giống như hồi sáng.
À tuy nhiên á là mình sẽ mở thêm để cho
mọi người hình dung cái câu chuyện là
mình sẽ làm được những gì, mình thử
những gì.
Thì gần đó là mình đây. Hồi nãy là mình
có nói với mọi người hãy check lại,
double check lại cái extension đúng
không bạn? Đây là mình sẽ làm nhanh để
cho mọi người thấy nè. Sau khi kết quả
là báo cáo đánh giá an toàn extension
cloud use trcker
thì nó báo về cho mình nè mọi người.
Tổng quan extension nè được thiết kế để
theo dõi lượng toen sử dụng trên
cloud.ai đồng bộ hóa dữ liệu, kết quả
phân tích bản nguồn mở. Dữ liệu được thu
thập là extension này có thu thập và lưu
trữ các thông tin sau để phục vụ tính
đồng bộ. Nghĩa là mọi người hình dung
khi mọi người cài bất cứ một cái app
nào, bất cứ một extension nào, tác giả
của cái người mà làm ra extension đó có
thể họ đang à sử dụng một cái mã code để
thu thập thông tin của mình được không
cả nhà?
Đó cho nên á không phải ứng dụng nào
miễn phí. Ở đây mình không ám chỉ bất kỳ
ai nếu anh em đang làm về code nha. Mình
không ám chỉ bất kỳ ai hết. Tuy nhiên ý
mình đang nói là nếu như cài đặt những
cái extension hay những cái phần mềm mà
mã nguồn nói chung là mở miễn phí thì
mọi người cũng lưu ý là nên cân nhắc xem
có cài đặt cái đó hay không vì không
phải cái nào miễn phí là cũng tốt. À nó
sẽ khai thác cái dữ liệu trên máy của
mình được chung cả nhà. Và thì trong này
nó có đây đề cập đến cái extension này
có thu thập thì trong đây nó thống kê nè
metadata, loại model mà mình đang sử
dụng là cái gì và thời gian, cột móc,
thiết bị đó sử dụng dữ liệu không được
thu tập. Đây là những cái đoạn chat nó
sẽ không thu tập nè. Quan trọng nhất là
qua kiểm tra thì cái tension thì không
có hành vi lấy cái dữ liệu là nội dung
chat thì tôi không lấy. Ok không cả nhà?
Thì kết luận lại là nó nói cái này là
không phải là spyware,
chức năng đúng cam kết được không? Đó
thì cái câu lệnh đây mình sẽ mở lại cái
luôn chat này. Mọi người bấm vào cái chỗ
ô này nó sẽ có mở lại cái coi là cái cái
cái lịch sử chat ha.
À đây phân tích
nè mọi người thấy nha. Mình cũng đánh
giống như cái tài liệu mà mình đã gửi
cho mọi người hãy lập kế hoạch tải về và
kiểm tra extension sau có thu thập data
người dùng và gửi về server của ngoại
không.
Rồi mình b cái cái tạo kết quả report
ghi chi tiết các rủi ro an toàn cho
người dùng nếu có được không cả nhà? Và
mình copy cái đường link extension đó
mình đến đây thì mọi người thấy không?
Cái anh này anảnh sẽ đi làm việc và anh
automation anảnh làm từ đầu đến đuôi
cuối cùng anh trả về kết quả báo cáo cho
mình. Nếu như cái AI bình thường sẽ
không làm được việc này đâu.
Đó thì như vậy mọi người hình dung ra
được
ờ cái câu chuyện em xin file tài liệu
anh Minh ơi.
À ok rồi bạn đợi một chút xíu
mình sẽ gửi lại.
Thì cái buổi hôm nay mục đích của Minh á
là muốn chia sẻ thêm với cả nhà á nếu
như mọi người đang quan tâm đến cái việc
mà nghiên cứu thị trường hay là làm mở
rộng hơn cho cái bệnh tư duy về trong
cái việc là sử dụng AI agent thì có thể
để ý đến cái công cụ Anti Gravity của
Google được không cả nhà? Rồi cái phần
trình bày của Minh tạm thời là hôm nay
Minh sẽ ngưng ở đây và nếu mọi người có
thắc mắc, mọi người có thêm câu hỏi mọi
người có thể bật mic ạ để mình cùng giao
lưu ạ.
À ừ mình mình ghi chi tiết nội dung cụ
thể rõ ra như mình có thể nói là cái ví
dụ như cái bay đó là cái bay của của một
cái đơn vị nào đó ví dụ như của một cái
đơn vị là công ty hay là một cái cái cái
tổ chức nào đó hay là tên nào đó cho nó
rõ ràng để nó vào nó cào
được không cả nhà? Vì hôm trước mình có
dự một cái buổi chia sẻ của anh anh anh
anh Nguyễn Duy Tùng thì hôm đó ảnh có
thị phạm về một cái bay đó là của
CocaCola
duy nhất một cái trang thôi đó là của
Coca thì sau đó cũng đi cào dữ liệu và
để để
xem thử các cái bên dưới á là mọi người
đang có hứng thú về cái buổi mà
cái cái cái sản phẩm mới hay không đó
vân vân.
À mọi người có thể bật mic lên và cùng
cùng đặt câu hỏi thêm ạ.
>> Alo chào anh Minh.
>> Dạ dạ xin chào bạn.
Tức là trong trong cái cái cái tính năng
này thì mình có thể ví dụ như mình mình
muốn tìm hiểu về một cái toàn bộ nội
dung của một cái trang cá nhân của một
người bạn mình chẳng hạn xem trước giờ
bạn mình quan tâm những chủ đề gì chẳng
hạn thì mình có thể thả cái link của
trang cá nhân đấy vào rồi và mình yêu
cầu nó cào toàn bộ ví dụ như là 1 năm 2
năm hoặc là 1 2 tháng chẳng hạn là gần
đây người đấy chia sẻ về nội dung gì
kiểu như vậy mình có làm cụ thể được như
vậy không?
Ờ cũng xin thưa với anh Thịnh là hiện
nay nhá mình cũng chưa thử đến cái
trường hợp trường hợp cụ thể đó nhưng mà
nhưng mà anh có thể thử giúp mình rồi
cho mọi người cùng kết quả tại vì bản
thân Minh hồi tối hôm qua đúng ra Minh
chị test à chỉ những cái câu cơ bản đó
đến thời điểm này luôn á là test về
TikTok nè test về mạng xã hội Redbit nè
mạng xã hội nè Facebook nè là chỉ những
cái câu mà mình lấy cái bài đăng ở cái
từ tháng 12 hay từ những cái thời gần
nhất chứ còn hiện nay là mình cũng chưa
đi lấy cái thông tin mà cào 1 năm hay là
trên một bay cụ thể anh Tịnh ơi.
>> Ok cảm ơn anh. Để mình thử xem sao.
>> Ok anh. Ok anh. Đây Minh sẽ mở lại một
cái báo cáo mà của
cái cái cái
trường hợp Minh đã đi đây.
Cái này là của bên YouTube. Minh cũng đi
lấy một cái chủ đề của kênh YouTube
nè. À này cũng là của bên YouTube.
Ok. thì hình như là nó chỉ có một số cái
phần
bài đăng
à cái này kế hoạch cho một cái kế hoạch
khác nữa. Vậy là cái bài lúc mà mình lấy
ở trên cái
chat đó mình không lưu lại cái phần của
TikTok mà x reddit đây nè. đó mà sao X
với Reddit thì mình lại không yêu cầu nó
lưu ở dưới dạng bên bên bên bên bên
file MD đây
>> em thấy cái này mà anh làm kiểu một cái
fanpage mà kiểu ngồi tổng hợp cái này
hàng ngày đăng lên cũng thu hút nhiều
vậy ta
>> đúng
>> anh làm chưa em nghĩ anh làm rồi
>> chưa đâu chưa chư nhưng mà á là chỉ
riêng cái việc mà từ hồi tối hôm qua lúc
mà 10 giờ hơn mình thử đăng có một bài
đó rồi sáng hôm nay nhưng mà nói như Huy
á nha chỉ mình đăng đúng ba bài từ tối
hôm qua đến nay thì lượt tương tác và
lượt view của mình tăng đến gọi là sao
ta chỉ trong một ngày duy nhất thôi tăng
lên tới 60 s mươi mấy ngàn ta có nghĩa
là tăng một mức độ kinh khủng chỉ để
tương tác những cái dạng này thôi mọi
người đang rất là quan tâm
>> à em thấy anh Minh đăng vào các group đó
đúng không anh
81.000.
Còn cái trang cá nhân á là đúng rồi,
đúng rồi. Huy đăng trên một số cái nền
tảng là chia sẻ trên các nền tảng các
group á. Còn cái fanpage là mình chưa
làm một cái gì hết á. Mình mình không có
làm fanpage gì hết á.
>> Ừ. Em thấy trang cá nhân thì vẫn của anh
thì vẫn ít nhưng mà trong cái
>> cái group thì nó lại ok. Mà trong mấy
group là duyệt bài ok không anh? Anh
thấy duyệt bài ổn không? Người ta kiểu
mình đăng lên thì duyệt bài người ta cho
nhiều.
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Cái này thì tùy thôi, tùy thôi. A
Huy ơi, có nghĩa là tùy theo cái mức độ
là mình đừng có spam, mình đừng có đưa
lên những cái bài mà vi phạm chính sách
cộng đồng thôi ha. Cái đó là nh
>> em thấy nù trên bình dân học ai anh
người ta comment quá trời nè mà anh chưa
ré nè.
>> Thật sự là quá nhiều à mình không có
thời gian mà mà tại vì mình còn làm
những cái việc khác nữa. Huy
>> à. Dạ em tính là hướng này cũng ok á nha
anh chị.
>> Đúng đúng đúng. Thì đó là một trong
những hướng đó đó là một trong những
cách nhưng mà Huy có thể nghiên cứu để
làm thêm một cái fanpage để làm những
cái cộng đồng riêng của mình.
>> Dạ. Trụ tính là bữa là bữa là cái cái
cái về Phật pháp là một cái ha. Xong cái
này nữa là hai cái có mà phân thân cái
buổi buổi buổi buổi thứ hai thì em không
có tham gia. Buổi thứ hai không biết anh
chia sẻ gì.
Ba
trợ
>> ờ hôm đó thì cũng chia sẻ gì để mình tự
nhiên mình quên đây.
>> Em cũng quên luôn. Em cũng nhớ em chỉ
nhớ là anh có buổi chiều á thì em không
tham gia được.
>> Ừ. Ok.
>> Dạ. cảm ơn.
>> À
lại tìm trên extension trên vậy anti này
thì tìm ở chỗ nào? À để coi cái câu này
ờ bạn định phải không ta? Bạn định là
hay là bạn nào đang hỏi là tìm ở đâu? À
à không bạn ấy trả lời rồi mọi người ơi
thường group nào bàn luận sơm về vai
code.
Ok còn anh chị nào mình mình có câu hỏi
mình tương tác nữa không cả nhà? Nếu mà
trong trường hợp mà mình không còn câu
hỏi á thì hôm nay Minh cũng xin tạm
ngưng ở đây. Còn về ứng dụng mà vi
coding thì hiện nay trên thị trường có
rất là nhiều ha. à ngoài cái ứng dụng
này tuy nhiên á là mình đang muốn đào
sâu cho nên hôm nay mình phát hiện ra
cái này hay nên cũng muốn chia sẻ với
cộng đồng mọi người à các bạn quan tâm
đến vấn đề về nghiên cứu hay research
thị trường bằng cái công cụ antiraffiti
này rất vui được mọi người tham dự cùng
mình trong buổi tối hôm nay
thì không biết còn anh chị nào có có
quan tâm mọi người cứ bật mic còn nếu
không còn gì thì à anh Chị em mình có
thể óc ạ.
>> Ok. Cảm ơn anh.
>> Anh anh Sơn ơi, không biết là anh anh
làm trong lĩnh vực nào ta?
>> À mình làm về đào tạo với khai vấn, mình
làm kinh doanh. Mình đang cũng tìm hiểu
về cái này để làm một cái thương mại
điện tử bên mảng nông nghiệp nữ Minh.
>> Dạ. Tại vì
thật ra á nếu như mà làm về những cái
mảng này lúc trước á nha Minh có từng
thử những cái công cụ như AI ví dụ như
là của Flow X nè hay là Manus hay là
Zenb thì không biết là anh đã đã có ứng
dụng nhiều chưa thì em không rõ nhưng mà
nếu mà mình sử dụng thì anh khai thác
cho cái mãng đào tạo hay là mãng kinh
doanh của anh em thấy rất là là là ok
luôn tại vì riêng cái này nhá nếu mà
mình đóng gói lại mà theo em á em đang
sử dụng á mà em chỉ khai thác nếu mà mọi
người để ý luôn mình chỉ mới làm từ đúng
hồi tối hôm qua chứ mình chưa hề làm cái
gì hơn mọi người nhé mình chỉ đi mới từ
hồi tối hôm qua luôn đó
bắt đầu chính xác là 10 giờ mấy phút hồi
tối hôm qua mình mới đăng nếu mọi người
nhìn lại bài đăng của mình thì mọi người
thấy thì cái này nó thật sự nó rất là
hữu ích
à nếu nên nên nên nên sơn với mọi người
có thể khai thác thêm
ở trên cái nền tảng
Dạ.
>> Ừ, cảm ơn Minh. Hôm hôm nay mình nhìn
cái nhóm này mình mới à nhìn cái bài của
Minh trên nhóm AI Masterm ấ thì mình mới
nhảy vào. Vì ngày xưa mình có tham gia
một cái webinar của bạn Bình Vương
Nguyên Bình ấy.
>> Thì thì cái cách tiếp cận của Bình cũng
hay nhưng mà nó hơi hơi dài.
>> Thì mình thấy cái cái này là một cái
công cụ rất là dễ dùng cho tất cả mọi
người.
>> Đúng. Trước đây mình có tham gia một cái
buổi của anh Vương Nguyên Bình có chia
sẻ về cách đi raw dữ liệu này. Có có xem
cái buổi hôm đó đúng không? Chắc là buổi
hôm đó qu cùng cùng một buổi đấy.
[tiếng cười]
>> Hôm nay có mình với Dũng Dũng dễ dãi. Ừ.
>> Đấy cũng viết extension để viết ra những
cái app nữa để đi lấy đó. Nhưng mà nó
đúng là mình sau cái lần đó đi thì tới
thời điểm này thì tới thời điểm này thì
mình theo mình cái công cụ này là quá
tuyệt vời luôn.
Mình mình ngồi mình qua mình đã thử cũng
khá khá rồi đó. Nếu mọi người nhìn thấy
ờ ngoài cái này ra mình còn làm được rất
là nhiều thứ
đó. Nó có thể viết ra một cái app
ở đây chia sẻ thêm nha. Ở đây mình có
làm thử nhưng mà lúc đó nó chưa thành
công thôi là nếu như mọi người có một
cái dự án một cái ứng dụng phần mềm làm
bên Google A Studio mọi người tải về
được không? Bên Google A Studio mọi
người tải về. Sau đó mọi người qua bên
này file open nó lên. cái thư mục file
đó lên thì bên này mình có thể tiếp tục
mình thao tác và nó fit lỗi nhanh hơn
bên Google AI Studio rất là nhiều rất
nhiều luôn.
À tại vì cái công cụ này nó chuyên dùng
để cho mục đích là vi code cho nên nó đã
cũng được tích hợp cái ô chat và cái
những cái model rất là cao cấp này từ
cái khả năng sửa lỗi. Tại vì trước đó là
mình có coi có tham gia một cái cái buổi
của một bạn nữa cũng đi fix lỗi ứng dụng
của Google Air Studio á xóa đi những cái
dòng code ngẫu nhiên ở trên Google i
Studio. Sau đó lưu lại nó lỗi luôn nhé.
Sau đó lưu lại mang về bên này và chỉ
yêu cầu nó là hãy khắc phục cái lỗi cơ
bản là bây giờ tôi đang là viết ứng dụng
gì đó là khắc phục lỗi giúp tôi và tìm
cái lỗi đó khắc phục. Nó chỉ chạy có tí
xíu thôi là nó fit cái lỗi đó ngay.
Yeah.